تطور طبي مبشر في مساعي الحد من مرض
السكري وعلاجه بعد ان تمكن علماء من
اختراق الخلايا البشريه التي تنتج
الانسولين العلماء توصلوا بفضل ذلك الى
عكس مرض السكري لدى الفئران وفق دراسه
حديثه نشرتها مجله
فالعلماء اعادوا توظيف خلايا المعده
البشريه لاطلاق الانسولين ما مكن من اداره
مرض السكري من النوع الاول بشكل فعال كشفت
التجربه التي قادها بحيثون من وايلد
ماديسون في الولايات المتحده ان عمليات
زرع خلايا افراز الانسولين في المعده عكست
مرض السكري في الفئران فهرمون الانسولين
بالغ الاهميه في تنظيم نسبه الجلوكوز في
الدم وعندما لا ينتجه الجسم بشكل كافي
تكون هناك مضاعفات خطيره اما الباحثون
يعملون ان يساعد البحث في دفع الجسم الى
انتاج الانسولين بشكل طبيعي مره اخرى
لمرضى السكري الذي يعتبر واحدا من اسرع
الامراض المزمنه انتشارا على مستوى العالم
وفقا لدراسه اجريت في عام 2022
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات